what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest
in one of the final chapters of the
attack on titan manga we've been told
that the manga will end in april which
means we are pretty much at the end of
the story
that should mean only three chapters
left after this one
every chapter really counts right now so
make sure to stay tuned for this insane
one
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time reviews and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is warhammer
smash that like button and share this
video with any attack on time fans that
you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next insane chapter to
drop feel free to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans ranked for weakens the strongest
and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so this chapter chapter
136 is called devote your hearts
last chapter we finally got the long
awaited appearance of the flying titan
in the form of falco's draw titan
they left for the time being peak on
aaron's titan and armin on aaron's titan
as well
as you'll remember they had to get out
of there because aaron's giant skeletal
titan was being overrun by countless
past titan shifters that aaron and amir
were summoning and controlling there
were beast titans warhammer titans and
all the other ones too
right now they're dealing with
unwinnable conditions against aaron and
i feel like if they win
it will only be because aaron willed it
so that they can come off as the heroes
who saved the world from the ultimate
devil aaron jaeger that way his friends
will no longer be treated as devils who
need to be eradicated but as heroes of
the world
as i mentioned before if aaron really
wanted to win
with the founding titan power he should
be able to control the other titan
shifters like reiner's armored titan
or the flying titan and so on but he
purposely decided not to do that
so clearly his goal is not to win at all
costs
and that makes sense because according
to him he is doing this for the people
who bore and raised him the people of
paradise island
and it's mostly these people including
gene connie levi
armin and mikasa who are trying to stop
him now if he killed them that would
defeat the purpose of what he's doing
on the flying titan reiner is not too
happy to see gabby his little cousin who
he wanted to protect and keep safe
now she's in the most dangerous place in
the world they explained that the
azumabito ship did indeed sink from
falco's flying titan transformation
kiyomi did have small backup boats so
she and the others are safe but gabby
wants to pay kiyomi's kindness
back by stopping the rumbling i'd like
to know how you guys feel about gabby
right now
she was a pretty hated character in the
beginning and i'm wondering if anyone's
changed their minds about her
she did a lot of horrible things no
doubt but you gotta admit she's a much
less
brainwashed person than she was then and
she acts a lot less arrogant and cocky
than she did before
reiner asks falco if he remembers his
promise to keep gabby safe
and falco thinks himself of course he
does he's still committed to saving
gabby from the dark future they face
at this point it seems likely that aaron
won't make it out of this series alive
after all he's done it's hard to believe
that he'll go back to a carefree life
but it is more likely that the following
generation gabby and falco will be able
to live in peace
and you might think that falco's time is
limited because of amir's curse
but not necessarily as we'll get to in
this chapter the spine-like creature
that gave amir fritz titan powers
is brought up here they know about that
creature and are probably prepared to
target that creature
when aaron's head gets detached now if
they do manage to destroy it it is
possible that titan powers will cease to
exist
and those with the powers will no longer
be affected by amir's curse
so armin falco and maybe others will get
a less depressing ending we shall see
but i can totally see something like
that happening that way
ldns get to live on and reproduce and at
the same time the threat of titans
ceases to exist
i am definitely appreciating annie and
armin's developing romance
she's clearly concerned about armin but
she doesn't want to make it super clear
to the others
she's a warrior so she should have asked
about pique first but she actually found
herself worrying about armin first a
cute moment in the middle of all this
insanity
at this point i can definitely see these
two having a happier ending than aaron
and mikasa before annie promises to save
armin
she says something pretty hilarious she
tells mikasa that her childhood friends
love getting kidnapped
it's easy to think back to aaron getting
kidnapped by reiner and bertolt and
other parts too
and now armin getting kidnapped again a
funny little detail and i enjoyed it a
lot
it shows that these characters do have a
lot of history together and even when
things look horrible in life you gotta
be able to crack some jokes and isayama
gets that
in fact sometimes the less funny a
situation is the funnier the jokes can
end up being
levi makes the decision to go back one
group will save armon
the other will attack aaron's nape that
has been surrounded with explosives
thanks to peak
here we have a really serious moment
where levi says they can no longer
concern themselves with air and safety
in fact they never had that luxury mika
says horrified to hear him say that
she's been defending aaron all along
despite it getting harder and harder to
defend his actions
everyone else agrees with levi including
connie and gene
connie says that they would be dead if
not for the flying titan saving them
which i have my doubts about personally
they may have been captured like armin
perhaps but i can't see aaron killing
mikasa personally
either way though gene agrees with
connie that they have to kill
aaron as a tear appears in mikasa's eye
and he tells her to just focus on saving
armin and not to think about aaron being
killed and mikasa agrees to this
though clearly bothered and that's a
huge turning point for her if she can go
along with a plan that would kill aaron
she clearly can't be an ackerman slave
programmed to protect aaron at all costs
so ironically her going along with this
plan
actually seems to prove that she's not a
brainwashed slave but rather someone who
really does care about aaron of her own
free will
this is when gabby points out the
centipede-like creature that jumped out
of aaron's spine
when she shot him using an anti-titan
rifle and by the way how crazy is it
that they have
anti-titan rifles but moving on as gabby
points out this creature isn't just the
founding titan
it's the true nature of the power of the
titans and because of that
it makes sense that the one who has it
can control and affect
all titans including the other titan
shifters who
are in reality drawing all of their
powers from this creature too
if they manage to kill this creature my
bet as mentioned
is that all titan-related powers will
cease to exist
i love getting more info on this
creature and i can't wait to learn even
more about its exact nature
as we move towards the end at breakneck
speeds we then get an amazing visual of
falco's jaw titan flying overhead it's
very cool to see
and i really appreciate any panels we
get showing off this miraculous titan as
the teams head back one to attack
aaron's nape the other to save armon we
jump to the remaining military
stronghold where marlene soldiers are
loading cannons even though they
probably know it's worthless and won't
make a difference
they keep working on it thinking it's
better than doing nothing it's better
than just
accepting death without a fight which
would ironically be aaron's view as well
the eldean refugees show up including
annie's dad
and they don't have armbands on anymore
this is very symbolic here they're no
longer going
to be treated as slaves and
discriminated against as lesser beings
and death is the great equalizer no
matter where you come from or how rich
or poor you are or anything else
all humans share the fate of having to
die eventually
and here they're facing that equalizer
in the form of
aaron they're not going to die wearing
the armbands that represented their
subjugation
but it's not revenge or a fight they
want with the marlands
they just want help for their wounded
but then both sides start pointing
rifles at each other
even as the end of the world is at hand
for their marlenes they're worried
because they know how much this group
has been mistreated
and that they probably want revenge and
it scares them to see them rising up
especially since
they have no more sub-human armbands and
they do have pointed rifles
annie's dad tries to calm his side down
but with the marlenes pointing guns at
them
and the fact that the marlenes have sent
aldeans to the front lines many times to
fight their wars
and the fact that the aliens finally
seem to outnumber the marlians in men
and firepower it's going to be hard to
defuse the situation
more marlene show up there is fear and
panic
the marlene leader in this situation
mueller shows up and he's got a gun he
previously suggested he changed his way
since marlene treatment of aldians
brought on aaron's apocalyptic attack in
the first place but
now we'll see if he was being honest or
if he's just another hypocrite
before this standoff gets resolved we
jump to the titans
but not going to lie this cliffhanger is
very intense for me as well
and i really want to know what's going
to happen between these two groups
is the cycle of hatred going to end as
they unite against a common monstrous
enemy
or will they end up killing themselves
before aaron can even get them with the
rumbling
is the older generation already a lost
cause and will hope have to rest with
the younger generation
we'll have to wait and see but let me
know your thoughts in the comments
it was very cool seeing all of these
warhammer titan designs in this chapter
as the flying titan approaches we see a
bunch of warhammer titans who all
formed long range weapons like bow and
arrows crossbows and throwing spears and
they launched them at the flying titan
fun fact one even reminds me of robocop
falco though can speed up and we see him
do it he goes so fast the others visibly
have trouble holding on
so even in his flying form as i
predicted he has access to a
characteristic
jaw titan speed remember the jot titan
is the swiftest of all
and thus it's the best for dodging these
long distance attacks
it's very impressive seeing falco's
titan make its way through the arrows
without getting hit the
design definitely seems very aerodynamic
gene and reiner go first after the
warhammer titan that has punctured peak
around where aaron's nape is and mikasa
actually shows concern for gene and
reiner while connie begs them not to die
it's crazy to see reiner after
everything he's done
getting the acceptance now and care of
the survey corps members the marlene
warriors namely zeke turned connie's mom
into a titan and now he's begging one of
them not to die
there's so much complexity in this one
battle when it comes to everyone's
backstory and what they've been through
and how they relate to each other and
whose side they're on now for mikasa
there's no doubt that she is torn and
she will probably have regrets no matter
who comes out
the winner in the end now we get a good
old-fashioned titan brawl
where reiner is slicing off the titan
heads of past titan shifters with his
hardened karate chops
reiner somewhat clears the way for gene
but as he goes to detonate the bomb the
previously clear path gets filled with
more and more titans emerging from the
skeletal body as the tiber sisters
version of the warhammer titan seems to
be distracted by gene
pique makes her way out of the cart
titan showing she's clearly not out of
commission
not even close in many ways i'd say peak
shines more than anyone else in this
chapter
although i've tried to make it clear
that the kartine definitely has its
strengths in past videos people still
kind of consider it a joke
and i get why because even its name
makes it seem like a glorified cart that
is only good for transporting cargo
however even before this moment i
stressed its insane speed that caught
levi off guard and thus saved zeke its
endurance that lets it stay transformed
for over two months in a row
and its ability to carry weapons
including anti-titan artillery all of
these things make the cart titan
interesting and useful on their own
but in this chapter we also get to see
peak using the power in combat to kick
butt quickly going after titan napes it
gets the warhammer titan in another
titan
and gene who sees it can't help but be
impressed
for a second it starts to seem like it's
all over for peak like other titans will
finish her off finally
but she uses the focused and controlled
steam emission ability that i mentioned
in my recent all 20 titan shifters in
their powers explained video
except she uses it to send her human
body flying away from her doomed titan
body and while in the air transforms for
a third time telling jean and i quote if
you think i'm a titan that's only good
for odd jobs and not fighting you're
dead wrong
and quote this is an epic moment and
she's pretty much speaking to all the
doubters and readers who slept on the
card titan up to this point she takes
out another titan and launches herself
like a missile again
to avoid another doomed titan body and
transforms for the fourth time taking
another titan out
so she just took out four other titans
and she says with the cartines endurance
so
long as they don't kill her she can
fight until they win
even if she has to try hundreds of times
which implies she can do hundreds of
transformations which is insane since
three transformations in a row is
impressive for most of the other titan
shifters and the colossal titan is even
more limited
she might be going a bit overboard in
her claim so that jean won't worry about
her and will carry out the mission
but what we saw already is impressive
enough to completely change people's
perception of how cool the car titan can
be
and how useful it can be in combat
specifically quickly though pique admits
to herself that even if she did kill a
hundred
which would be amazing that wouldn't
mean much against a million enemies so
she was mostly putting on a brave front
as i expected
and gene is so outnumbered and
overpowered that he ends up chilling
under the skeletal body
probably wondering how he can possibly
complete his mission with all of these
past titan shifters around they can't
kill them as fast as they're showing up
we
jump to the other team and annie is mad
to see bento's colossal titan being used
as one of aaron and amir fritz's titan
puppets
they definitely don't have an easy task
ahead of them here they have to find one
titan that swallowed armin
out of all the titans present they
wonder if it's a pig one a beast one a
cart one or maybe a jaw one
luckily connie notices that only one is
running away
so they conclude that it has to be that
one and they say it's an okapi
and that may not be the way it's
pronounced and i had no idea what this
animal was but it turns out to be
related to giraffes
but looks like a cross between a deer
and a zebra never thought that i'd
learned so much about the animal kingdom
from attack on titan
adding even more humor to the mix i've
already mentioned three different
animals
and annie then calls it and i quote a
pig or whatever it is
end quote i've never seen an animal that
looks like a cross between so many
different things
it's pretty fascinating connie annie and
mikasa then jump
off of the flying titan to catch this
titan and we stick with the flying titan
with levi and gabby on its back
like i said before it's so crazy to me
that she actually has an anti-titan
rifle but levi says that it won't be
able to kill
any of these titans levi still wishes he
could kill zeke
carry out his promise to erwin but as he
mentioned he'd just be a burden in this
state
crazy to think that we've gotten to the
point where even levi can't do much
when he was by far the strongest
character at certain points in the story
leaps and bounds ahead of the others but
more and more strong forces and powers
kept showing up while he got
nerfed thanks to the beast titan and
that explosion
levi reminisces about his life his
generation's role
and thinks it might have ended after he
got those three
meaning air and mika sent armin to the
sea but it's haunting levi
because that ended up with this
situation with aaron trampling on the
hearts and lives of most of the world
levi hates to think that all of his
comrades died just so this could happen
that they devoted themselves for this
hell and at times like this even people
like levi have to question
if the king within the walls was right
when he surrounded humanity with titans
and kept them in the walls
in a way it was a paradise compared to
what is happening now that they killed
the titans and moved beyond the walls i
don't think any of the conflicting paths
that the characters have chosen are
obviously 100 the right choice
and that's what makes attack on titan a
compelling story people are trying their
best to create their versions
of a lesser evil while preventing other
people's versions
of lesser evils from coming about levi
thinks their dream of a world without
titans was absurdly innocent and
idealized
and it had to be for them to devote what
they did little did they know
that a much greater threat was waiting
for them after they wiped out the titans
on the island despite
everything levi says he doesn't regret
picking armin over erwin
and entrusting the future to the kid who
had the same eyes as erwin by which he
probably means the hopeful eyes of an
idealist
levi is okay with trusting the next
generation to come up with a better
future
even if he couldn't and armin really
does have more of an idealized view than
aaron
and was always trying to find a way to
compromise when aaron thought that a
compromise was realistically not an
option
he wanted to save the aldians but also
didn't want to sacrifice the rest of the
world to do it he wanted to stop aaron
but also didn't want to kill him it's
going to be interesting to see
in the following chapters what approach
the story endorses if any
will armin end up being right or will
the story end up
showing that he was naive in his
imagined win-win scenarios
i can't wait to find out as mikasa annie
and connie try to corner the so-called
pig titan
it starts running towards aaron's head
and the titan shifters are really well
organized while annie launches mikasa in
a very dope maneuver
other titans block the target so mikasa
can't rescue armin on the bright side
this does prove
that they are probably after the right
titan mikasa makes quick work of the two
blocking titans but then an
armored titan shows up its armor is so
strong that it causes mikasa's blades to
break
and then she is saved by annie's
hardened kick
i gotta say as far as action and
fighting go this has got to be one of
the best chapters of attack on titan yet
the titan thereafter goes heading for
bertolt's titan as the three get more
and more surrounded by enemy titans the
question is
is there any chance that bertolt's will
can influence that colossal titan at
this point
or as it seems is it doomed to remain a
pure puppet we shall have to wait and
see because then we jump to armin
looking at himself he wonders why his
body won't move
and hates himself for being useless
while everyone is about to die
he uses really harsh self-talk here
calling himself a useless idiot and many
other things but to no avail
it's an interesting part from a
psychological perspective as
armin says to himself that he's always
hated himself and
that he's never done anything but betray
himself harsh words considering how much
armin has arguably accomplished in the
story but it does seem like we're
usually harder on ourselves than we are
on others
he thinks he hasn't been able to give
anything to
others despite being given life
expectations and responsibilities
he realizes pretty soon that he's in the
world of paths
he notices that he is in fact still
alive as i guessed last chapter
i don't think aaron would have killed
him but he is taken out of commission so
he can't
fight for the time being even though
he's in this parallel world of paths
he still knows what everyone is doing
because all aldeans are connected by
this path
he thinks that he might be able to do
something from here an interesting idea
before he sees zeke
building up a hill of sand just like a
child zeke looks depressed like he's
given up all hope and he says it looks
like amir fritz has eaten armin
too just like she ate him and that's the
end of this action-packed and
insane chapter as i guessed previously
aaron should be able to use armin's
colossal titan now
since he used zeke's beast titan and now
armin is in the same place that zeke was
i also have to mention that armin and
zeke as far as we know
are the most intelligent characters that
are still alive in the series and i'm
not just relying on common sense here
i'm relying on the data books as well
armin was just trying to come up with
something he could do in this parallel
world
and it's suggested here at least in my
view that these two
will put their insane genius level minds
together
and come up with a plan but clearly zeke
will have to be thrown out of his funk
first since he looks like he already
gave up on changing anything
but wow what craziness we have aaron in
possession of the current founding titan
attack titan warhammer titan beast titan
colossal titan
not to mention all past titan shifters
we got the two smartest characters
face to face possibly going to work
together to try to come up with some
kind of plan
we got a flying titan peak kicking butt
and a mikasa
annie team up things could not be more
interesting right now and i can't wait
to see what happens in the next chapter
as always give me your thoughts on this
chapter in the comments
and let me know what you expect to see
happening next do you think armin
and zeke will be able to do anything
from this parallel world or
is it a lost cause if you did enjoy this
chapter review and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button
absolutely obliterate it if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos and while you wait for the
next chapter review to drop
feel free to check out my growing attack
on titan playlist where we got videos
about all the titan shifters and their
powers all the ackermans and their
powers
the titans ranked from weakest to
strongest in a lot more very interesting
videos so link to those are in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans ingrata the world
acquire respect pate hefarithian emperor
otaku spidey life tinel fake buddhist
and tungsten tarkis and our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazowski
joel stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond ruthu and aura alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly
saint matthew cruz anthony schreiber hi
jinx and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime up for a link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you